so I don't think I can I mean I look
through our slack meetings there's a
problem which is that Michael is
effectively always correct and on a good
day I try to be correct like 10% of the
time that might be generous so most of
our slack meetings are long seasons of
me saying something I'm mr. Jang I'm
saying
huh what I don't understand
and then eventually would say I'm
getting sleepy so yeah so Aaron Suk was
I guess you proved the yeah the the
faster the algorithm is slower to talk
but was it was very it was technical
I'll try to be less technical because
one of those I mean one of the things
that I'll miss most perhaps from a
selfish perspective is just Michael had
a really strong intellectual curiosity
and so what it means is if you found
something beautiful and you got him to
think it was beautiful like that was
just really cool so let me tell you a
little about my sort of experiences
Michael over the last three three or
four years and and some of the things
some of the ideas he thought were were
cool and then if hopefully there's time
I'll I'll give you another example of
one of these arguments where things were
very complicated and he just did it the
correct way so it's so that even maybe
seems straightforward in retrospect but
the first time I met Michael was I think
in Providence April 2014 I know because
I have a a chat with my girlfriend where
I describe extremely persistent kid from
MIT I'm assuming it was Michael and he
was he was working with Richard paying
on this problem of the following problem
you have D by n or n by D matrix so this
is switch colors linear operators so
this is just a matrix and you should
think about D as being much smaller than
n so you're mapping some D dimensional
subspace into a n-dimensional ins you
know some subspace some D dimensional
space into a small subspace to some
bigger dimensional space so what you
could try to do is you could try to
approximate this map by something where
the dimension in the image was much
smaller okay so what I mean by this is
maybe come up with some a prime a little
D into big D dimensions where now we
want Big D to be much smaller than N and
we want to preserve some properties of a
and in fact maybe even but even better
we just want we just want to a prime to
be some subset of the of the rows of a
so just choose a subset of rows of a so
that we preserve some properties of the
map a and maybe the most natural thing
you could do is ask that you preserve
the the norms of all the vectors under
this mapping
it has some kind of like for some kind
of condition like this for all four
Alexia Rd so okay and again so think
about a prime is choosing a subset of
the rows in a so the case P equals two
is a it's pretty
I mean classical is not the right word
but pretty well understood at this point
does anybody has anybody who does not
consider themselves an expert no I know
how to do it for P equals two like well
how do you sample a prime the how do you
sample the rows yes that's that was
right in fact you're the person that had
in mind I was gonna give you a hard time
so these you're not an expert yeah so
you say important sampling where you use
sample rows proportional to weights that
look something like
like this so AI are the rules of the
rows of a this represents how important
the row is to the to the span there so
for instance I mean one instantiation of
this is if you if if a is a if K is
coming from a laplacian so the a is
correspond to the edges then this would
correspond to sampling according to
effective resistances so that's what
happens you want to preserve the the the
two norm but you can ask about maybe the
next most natural thing to think about
is what about P equals one and so this
is what Michael was asking about in in
2014 because him Indian Richard Peng had
had some notion that Holograms might be
solving this problem in one of his
papers and in fact only now I'm sort of
the thinking about you know talking
about some of Michael's work that I go
back and look at what they what they did
there eventually and it's it's a really
beautiful treatment of something called
louis weights which are that if you care
about LP norms instead of l2 norms then
there's a there's another notion of
leverage score that you should use to
sample so in the case p equals 1 the
notion is you want to choose weights
that satisfy the following
so these are the these are the weights
you want to use and then okay sorry when
I say these are the weights what does it
mean so it's not even this is a circular
definition of the WI so it's not clear
that such things exist but you can write
down an optimization problem for which
these WH are good solution and they
exist for every for every P you can do
this very P greater equal to one this is
the this is the condition you want for P
equals 1 and then if you sample if you
sample with respect to these weights
then actually telegrams showed in 1990
that you can you can match what's known
in the Euclidian case so so what I mean
what Michael and Richard did was first
of all they understood what's going on
there from a CS perspective so in
particular they you know they managed to
do all of this sampling in input
sparsity time very fast but also they I
would take a look at the paper is it
this really nice thing that computer
scientists do when they read math papers
which is like to want to think about
everything from scratch which is sort of
can be frustrating but also you know
leads to a lot of really beautiful
insights so yeah so these papers is
really great let me just say here to
lead on to the next thing that the
what's the major problem in analyzing
this you have this a prime it's a random
matrix use a random subset of the rows
but then this condition has is you have
some conditioning when told for every
vector in Rd right so so you can't
really take just a naive Union bound
here over all the you know you can't
just say well it for every vector I do
well and I just take a naive Union I
mean there's any friendly many vectors
so you end up with looking at for
instance sort of yeah so you end up
needing more clever Union balance one of
the cases in which like maybe the most
classical area in which that arises is
the study of Gaussian processes
and actually that brings me to sort of
the another conversation now remember
with Michael from 2016 we were at Banff
and there's this Banff Airport er that
you take for two hours from the Calgary
Airport to Bev and I just come back from
Prague actually from Yuri Matus ex
memorial conference and I was I was
really tired and kind of grumpy and so I
just wanted to sleep and put on my
headphones and I saw Michael on the
shuttle and I'm like okay go because
he's so I tried to indicate that I was
you know I put my headphones on side and
but then I have to say that like Michael
really drew me out of my shell he had
just come back from actually this what I
think it works chaining workshop that
Jelani was organized and so he started
asking me about is that was that 2016 so
this was yeah this was in July or I
think or August and so he started I
started asking so you know James I saw
on your on your blog you know you do
this major I think measures theory but
you don't prove this lemma of slap Ian
and and I said yeah it's you have to you
know do some stuff and he's like well do
you know how to prove it and so you know
like the end result is that we just I'm
sure annoyed everyone else on the
shuttle for the next two hours by trying
to reconstruct because of what I told
him was it actually groma of claims that
this was proved by Archimedes let me
just tell you so seriously and and
Michael really liked this idea so we
spent the next two hours trying to
reconstruct Archimedes proof I mean the
purported proof of Archimedes so so okay
so let me just tell you what what slab
Ian's Lama is in a simple language so
so you take a and vectors in Rd and then
let's take some other vectors Y one
through I am lion and we want the
following property that all the pairwise
distances between the X eyes are smaller
than or most all the pairwise distances
between the between the Wyatt so we take
some right to families of vectors all
the X eyes are correspondingly closer
together than the Y eyes then what
slurpeeninja lemma says is that the
expected so now you're gonna choose a
random direction and you're gonna look
at the expected maximum projection of
some vector in that direction
so random Direction means that this this
G is a dimensional Gaussian so mean zero
identity covariance and the [ __ ] means
Lama says that this is if all the
pairwise ins are smaller than actually
the expected maximum projection over the
excise is smaller than the expected
maximum over the over the widest okay
and the point of the the connection here
is that here you're looking at a maximum
which is the same kind of thing you're
looking at here and in fact the way that
telegram analyzes this is by using
Gaussian processes but the idea here is
that yeah if you're if you if you have
if X is strictly closer together or
sorry is that most it's closer together
than the Y's then the expect the
expected maximum is smaller than
expected maximum for the wires like what
if you move on the excise pretty far
from origin maybe there is some
assumption the center is the origin
what's wrong everything is transit yes
this is I mean that you have expectation
zero so it's expected what's well push
all the excise together very fact of the
origin than the maximum I mean you're
you you're gonna get I mean first of all
you're gonna kill you know half the time
now you're gonna get a large negative
term for instance from this thing and
it's gonna kill some other so so he okay
so what it's advice is to do is look at
the soul okay this is true but you just
look at you just subtract one vector
subtract the fix vector from all the
exercise look at the expected maximum
that will come out in as X takes is zero
so you can translate everything back to
the the origin okay so so here is the so
consider the same setup and now suppose
you also have some numbers r1 through RN
there are those are some radii then here
is the fact which gromova tributes to to
Archimedes which is that if you look at
the intersection of all the balls around
the excise look at the volume of that
intersection there's a bunch of balls in
Euclidean space take their intersection
pick the volume then the claim is that
this should be monotone when the
distances are all when all the pairwise
distances are decreasing
it makes sense you have a bunch of
excise that where the pairwise seasons
are smaller than the Y's then the
intersection of any family of balls
around those centers has larger volume
than for the Y's and in fact it's not so
hard to show that those two things are
equivalent and then and then what Gromov
says is that this this fact must have
been known to at least two Archimedes
certainly by the 17th century was well
established with no references but it's
it's it's it's it's kind of it's amusing
first of all because for instance even
the fact that the intersection of these
balls being non-empty implies that the
intersection of the balls around around
wise is a is not empty this is due to
cache Brown it's the main Stepan's what
is called Chris Brown's extension
theorem so so I will just say that
with only a little bit of cheating
Michael did manage to to figure out the
good Lord paying attention yeah
Michael did manage to figure this out
once I and so I'm giving you guys the
same challenge once once I told him that
the the perhaps the key is that you can
given any two such such configurations
you can continuously move from one to
the other in a way where the the
Euclidean distances are always
decreasing the whole time so you can
start at time one you know at time zero
at though add the Y's and then move
continuously so that at time at time one
you're at the x's and all the pairwise
diseases are decreasing the whole time
so now you want to prove this across
along that process okay so now in the in
the last third of the talk let me tell
you how a really nice argument of
Michael that actually gets around
needing to use Gaussian processes and I
didn't know Jelani is gonna be here so
my fingers are crossed that I don't say
something
silly or offensive okay so this is about
these things yeah this subspace and
bearings so Michael has a paper I think
in soda 2016 analyzing these things in a
way which is sort of at least for me
obviously the right way to do things but
you didn't even you didn't make any
facial expression Jelani so I don't know
if it's so in that sense it's not
because because it's the log D okay but
it's still the best known result so that
the idea is is a is that you want to
have a
a random linear map so a random M by n
matrix from RN to RM in this case you
want to think about M is being smaller
than n and and you want so if you think
about for instance the classical Johnson
Lyndon Strauss ran a projection lemma
then that basically says that you want a
random linear map that preserves most
one dimensional subspaces but here you
can think about you want to do some kind
of numerical linear algebra you might
want to preserve some higher rank
structures if you want to do SVD
afterwards or regression or clustering
some kind of labeling so the condition
you want here is that it is the
following that with high probability you
preserve every D dimensional subspace
here so these pi is against a random
mapping a random linear map
I don't put a sounds governor nor Mitch
the two norm so this is the kind of
condition you want for all subspaces of
RN of dimension D so there are three
parameters in is D epsilon and Delta but
does it make sense so for every subspace
dimension D you want to preserve all the
norms in that subspace with good
probability so if there's some rank D
structure say hidden like you have some
other yeah you have some other if
there's some rank D structure you have I
mean this map PI is oblivious to kind of
whatever you care about right it's some
random mapping it doesn't depend on
anything else then but the point is that
this map will preserve some you know
like rank these structures with good
probability now if you only care about
some rank D structure then it's possible
that you can just do something D
dimensional afterwards like lucca this
is very I mean it's very similar to the
kind of thing we use in the spectral
partitioning for instance okay okay so I
if you want to if you want to use if
you're willing to take this matrix PI to
be dense then you can just use the
classical theory to analyze this but if
you want things to be really fast it
might it makes sense to take this to be
a sparse matrix and maybe the simplest
distribution over sparse matrices that
one can think I have pumped with matrix
dimensions I think this is
one of the simplest distributions you
can think of is to just put a constant
you know have the matrix be mostly zeros
but just put a constant number of
nonzero entries per column so so like
let's say s at most order one doesn't I
mean this is
entries per column and then if there's a
nonzero entry just choose it to be the
correct scaling is to make it let's say
something most things are zero if
something is nonzero then you make a
uniformly plus minus one over square
root of s alesis gives a very this is a
very sparse matrix has only a linear and
n number of nonzero entries it's much
harder to analyze this kind of thing for
such matrices because there's not very
much randomness you know sort of like if
you be taking Union bounds you want to
have lots of randomness there's not much
here so so previous analysis of these
things there's a very nice paper of Cain
and Nelson using some fairly technical
looking combinatorial arguments there's
a paper of a bargain what was this guy
Dietz what's this guy's name did stir
thinks think stir Dirksen that's I knew
it was something in that genre of name
Dirksen and and Jelani which is like 85
pages long or something is that an
underestimate doesn't this in a much
more general it does things in a more
general setting although okay you can
ask yourself if this can be done in a
more general setting you probably know
the answer so very much that's why you
would ask yourself but okay so let me
just say that so so so what did michael
prove here that the best known bounds in
this setting that this works when let's
say there's some parameter theta that
you get to choose you should choose a
bigger than one
not so important when all of these
things are but you can choose the
embedding dimension m to be roughly D
over epsilon squared times some other
stuff and you can do that with sparsity
the only real important thing here is
that this is this is tied up to the I
believe this is this this would be tied
up to this log defector I'm not exactly
sure okay
and previously the analysis of these
things at least lost some additional
poly log DS in in various places
yeah it's it's it's much faster to to
multiply by sparse matrix
yeah for denser dimension this is
there's enough I mean if you were it
depends but if you find me if this thing
was a random Gaussian matrix then then
that's really nice every subspace is the
same you should consider one subspace
okay so what's the yeah so let's let's
see if in three I think I get five
minutes but okay so in five minutes I
can just tell you Michael's very simple
idea so okay so this is the distribution
on matrices the first thing is sort of
the straightforward one that it suffice
is to to bound the following
so here this is the operator norm I'm
gonna write to the 2 norm
this is just the largest eigen value of
this matrix so if you can prove that the
largest I can derive this matrix is the
most Epsilon for every u that's that's
just that's an orthonormal basis
normal this is a it's not hard to check
here ever you series if you look at the
definition of the spectrum are it means
that these two things map every input
vector to be pretty close to you know by
the way this is the identity if if you
resolve this form
so you're just we just want to show that
for every for every such you which is an
orthonormal basis that this thing is
closed in the spectrum armed to the
identity and then okay so you can just
write this down not this
I'll write down the thing you care about
this is a this is a random matrix
it's an unbiased estimator so what
happens is if you for lack of time let
me just write what you get is you get
some basically diagonal terms that's
just u transpose U and then you get the
off diagonal terms so let's sum over our
sum over i not equal to j sigma r i
sigma r j UI UJ transpose okay these
Sigma's are these variables that are
mostly 0 sometimes plus or minus 1 over
square root of s so then okay so all
right well then subtract off now what
you really want to bound what you really
want to show is almost surely at most
epsilon is the spectral norm of of this
thing and and it's a natural thing to
want to do here which is you know just
define this to be some symmetric matrix
Z are these are here this is something
over the the rows right so
probably we wanted some want to be yeah
to define it to be zr and then to use a
matrix concentration down
it's like debts would be that's like if
you were coming in on day one you'd say
look have a bunch of matrices i want to
use a matrix concentration bomb the
problem that you confront is twofold
here one is that i guess the major
problem is that well these terms are not
independent because of the way we
selected things right i mean if you you
know if you tell me that there's a and
if you tell me this row obviously it
affects the distribution of the other
rules because I have exactly s nonzero
entries per column
so you can't really use a matrix as a
black box a matrix Chernoff bound you
know so I could just say that the the
proof works let me say one more thing I
mean the point is that instead of a
matrix Chernoff bound you can say well
you basically use a matrix version of a
Zuma's inequality which doesn't require
that the summons are independent it just
requires that conditioned on you know
some subset of rows you've seen so far
that you can say something nice about
the conditional distribution of the next
row
but it's also clearly doesn't work
because I mean if I if if if I you know
for instance if I tell you the the first
like if I tell you the first n minus 1
rows here and I don't know you see I
mean if there if you see all of the s
nonzero entries already then there's no
you know there's no variance left in
this entry or this entry what's more
painful prep probably is that this entry
could be forced to be one if you only
have s minus one things beforehand ok so
you so you just you just split the you
just split the matrix into two here is
only confusing because I mean M from
doing things with M instead of D for
some reason but yeah so so Michael just
says okay just split it into two pieces
and then just bound the bound this
quantity for each piece separately if
you've only revealed half the rows then
this is not really an issue like there's
like because I mean you have s is some
small number and so you you know if you
only revealed half the rules then you
can't I mean you can think about it it's
not particularly difficult to show that
that that sort of the conditional
distribution still has nice
concentration properties okay but that's
the whole that's all argument there's
one other step here and but it's it's
not involving decoupling but it's not
particularly like but like that's
amazing right that's the whole like you
just say okay so you say you want to use
the zoom ax so then you say well you
can't so just split it into pieces and I
have to take au niveau for twice as many
things and then you finish the proof
the cup okay there's something there's
something coupling here because if you
look at this term it looks almost like
it should be a square except it's not a
square because you have on R equal to J
but you can the decoupling argument says
you take this sum you write it as you
can write this sum of it as an
expectation over sums that look like it
look like this let me write it here
our eye what was the variable okay right
UI
so that sum is actually the expectation
of this sum over all random partitions
of the coordinates in the two sets and
therefore if you care about only if you
care about some convex functional of
this sum then you upper bounded by
ensign by a convex function of these
things now you're now you're left you
analyze say for every tea something of
this form but now notice that these two
parts are independent because they're on
these joint sets of coordinates so the
randomness here is independent so that's
the decoupling step so there is like
decoupling and then then you have to
deal with sort of the harder issue
that's this the fact that you might not
have very much rather than this left
once you condition so it just splits the
matrix in the two pieces and and then
analyzes each one separately they're not
they're not independent but it doesn't
matter you just increase the Union bound
by a factor of two
I like this proof because it's the kind
where like okay now I know how to prove
it like now you can you know you can be
in a you know on a era shuttle rides in
Banff and and somebody asks you know how
to prove that sparse random matrices are
good subspace embeddings just extra low
D in the bank comes from the fact that
we do matrix journal type things that is
an extra and in the community so you
know extra yes it's the in fact it was
if you remember the first part of the
talk there was a lot D that's the same
log D all those log these possibly can
be removed and we know the situations
where they can be removed be a Batson
Stillman Srivastava is one such
situation but they are all from taking a
union bound yeah if they're off here so
if you if you so it's true that if you
yes that you if you wanna get if you
want to take you get really this
dependence on D then you have logged the
entries per column
and just to say one more thing about
Michael let me say that all of these I
would you know people have been storing
sort of these one sentences and an Erin
mentioned like an interactive argument
to decipher what they mean so one of the
the minor unfortunate things about
Michael passing away is that when we
were trying to write our stock paper
which 7y untied and Olek the you know
the day before the deadline we spent
basically the entire day trying to
figure out what one of those sentences
means and we managed to do it but it
wasn't so easy for that one sentence
you want a yes or no answer because I
can't know but also each yes
I mean Hanson right you wanna usually
you want to bounce you want to bound
like chaos like degree two polynomials
and there and in variables but this is
all degree one so like sir I mean you
know you mean here because you have this
kind of thing this is not yeah but
that's not oh they do I mean the
coupling is something that goes on all
the time so also in Hanson right but
this is this is not really a quadratic I
mean you don't need to analyze it like a
quadratic decoupling happens all over
the place
so there is a actually a really good
paper of does a mean who's on the paper
with Ryan they have a paper that has a
nice survey of the coupling methods okay
Ryan O'Donnell and some and a student
who I don't remember
okay
[Applause]